hello John hello Hank we are Gabi and
Alison from just between us when they
asked us to do this video we were
excited because our channel is a comedy
channel and we rarely get real with our
talk I get real all the time you're
pretty real but I try to stay fake
that's why we're an odd couple that's
why this worked but there's been one
topic that a lot of people have been
asking us about that we've never really
addressed and we figured that this would
be a good opportunity to do it this is
my first vlog Congrats on your first one
thank you I feel different so that
question is why did we leave BuzzFeed we
left over a year ago it was probably one
of the scariest decisions we've ever had
to make
I agree the first few months there were
amazing I had had a writing job before
so I was less enthused about the whole
thing I don't think you're ever as
enthused as I am about anything that's
true it's very hard for me to feel joy
and I was also like 26 so it wasn't my
first job it wasn't I wasn't like a lot
of the other people there who were likes
just out of college now I feel
embarrassed that it was my first job
when I was 25 wasn't my first job but it
was my first job writing job yeah your
first writing job which is a big deal
and and it's like a scary thing to leave
I'd done a lot of writing for free but
it was also an incredible environment in
there all these people our own age we
were all like making stuff and I very
distinctly remember standing there
during like an all-hands meeting and
just thinking it's so sad that I can't
work here my entire life and so that's
what it was so interesting was like
after a few months went by when like
things kind of started to change where
it became clear that maybe that wasn't
where I was supposed to be for forever
that there was some pushback about the
fact that we had our own channel we were
in a sort of department where it wasn't
super clear like what we were supposed
to be doing and we also more like toying
with okay well did then do we get do we
get rid of just between us and commit
ourselves to BuzzFeed but that didn't
feel right to us either we were getting
interest from other people about doing
our own stuff we wanted to prioritize
just between us because that was growing
and just between us as ours
the thing about jobs is that you can
leave them and so they have to listen to
yourself and if like at a certain point
even if the company's great even if like
you had great experience there if it's
no longer the right fit like in a
relationship then you have to break up
when you work for a company in May
videos everything that you make that
company owns so for instance you might
have heard about some people being let
go from BuzzFeed and those people the
characters and the videos that they the
series that they created while at
BuzzFeed they'll never be able to make
that series ever again and that's
because that is BuzzFeed's intellectual
property and that began to scare me
where I was like well do I give them my
best ideas later in life I may want to
use those ideas for something and I
won't be able to and that started
worrying me more and more in the idea of
them owning anything to do with just
between us started worrying me more and
more I remain like so grateful to
BuzzFeed like I do not think that like
we would be where we are if we hadn't
had BuzzFeed I think it was incredible
exposure it was amazing
but at the same time you have to
remember that a company is always a
company and a company is not your friend
and so that's confusing because you're
working with all of your friends and all
the people that work there are your
friends but the company itself is not
your friend when I went into this
industry I knew that it was going to be
very unstable and it was gonna be kind
of chaotic and I wouldn't really I
wasn't really gonna know what was gonna
come next but I think one of the issues
is if you start working for one of those
big companies you kind of get tricked
and you're like oh I have stability and
I get to be creative but at a certain
point you have to remember that you need
to take risks in the end you only have
yourself and you only have what you've
made so like how do you know like to me
I kept whenever we were there I would
always think how do I know any of these
companies will be here in five years why
would I like marry myself to this thing
that I'm like have no guarantee of it
being around the only thing I knew would
be around was me and you hopefully if we
both live that's really if we both make
really optimistic but also like that's
the kind of personalities that we are
and there's so many people that like
like the way that they would be the most
happy is to stay at a company and work
there long-term but it just wasn't right
for us and I think that that's almost
like what we want to say the most is
like just listen to your gut and listen
to what feels right for you and like the
other side isn't roses yeah like work
it's constant stress we're constantly
upset we've been able to work on
projects and like strive towards
projects that are like so much bigger
than and then I think that what we could
have done if we stayed there and so much
more our own it's feels so uncomfortable
to be talking sincerely into a camera ah
yeah I'm really excited watching you do
it I'm like
where the jokes